c'est l'heure de la cueillette pour
michelle et ses deux enfants le repas du
soir sera confectionné uniquement avec
des aliments du jardin cette famille va
à l'épicerie à peine une fois par mois
ttc
cette vie loin de la ville michel et son
mari rob en rêve depuis 14 ans alors
qu'ils poursuivent une carrière à
calgary comme ingénieur dans le secteur
pétrolier il voyage en europe et en
amérique latine pour apprendre à réduire
leur empreinte écologique
on a vite réalisé qu'il fallait surtout
à prendre l'agriculture durable pour
assurer un bel avenir à nos enfants dit
elle le couple découvre la permaculture
un ensemble de méthodes agricoles plus
respectueuses des écosystèmes depuis
deux ans dans le centre de l'alberta la
famille opère un véritable retour à la
nature
notre but c'est de produire le moins de
déchets possible d'être des producteurs
plutôt que des consommateurs et de
rendre ce sol riche pour les décennies à
venir explique-t-elle
les enfants eux se sont vite adaptés
je préfère vivre ici dit naomi on peut
faire des randonnées sans prendre la
voiture et il y a toujours des choses à
faire dans le jardin cette vie au vert
n'empêche pas michel de travailler avec
son mari il donne des cours sur internet
pour partager leur savoir
leur chaîne youtube comptabilise plus de
6 millions de vues les visites sur leur
site ont doublé pendant la pandémie pour
l'instant ils ne produisent que la
moitié de leur nourriture et de leur
énergie leur prochain projet leur
permettra de récupérer l'eau de pluie il
leur faudra du temps et de l'argent pour
être réellement autosuffisant ici axel
tardieu radio canada winfield